Frank Strang MBA who is the chief
executive of saxophone Spaceport which
is a vertical Spaceport being
established in the Shetland Isles
Mr Strang is a former RF pilot and he's
joined by another former RAF pilot Dave
balance who is the launch operations
manager at the saxophone Spaceport
position that he's had since March 2020.
thank you very much indeed for coming
and for coming in person perhaps you
could just tell us how things are going
and when you expect the first launch to
to take place from your your Spaceport
apparently chairman just a small point
of order otherwise I'll get a hard time
from my pilot friends I wasn't a pilot
unfortunately but or fortunately but um
I was an Air Force officer so I think
yeah um so on another point I'd like to
make is saxophone we're not just about
vertical launch it's very important to
understand that what we're building is a
Spaceport so I need diversity of income
and we need to build a sustainable a
sustainable business so our business
model is based about about launch
Bringing Down the data from the
satellites and also accommodation and
support services so we're not relying on
one thing
um to date and we got planning
permission
on the 23rd of March last year and since
then we've spent 28 million pounds of
our money
um we have
built New Roads and we've crafted out
three launch pads we've laid the
concrete in steel for Launch Pad one
launch pad Fredo which is the first new
orbital vertical orbital launch site in
Europe and one of our clients in rocket
Factory Augsburg have erected their
launch stool about 13 million euros
worth of infrastructure on our site
um our one of our other clients who
you're talking to later High impulse
have conducted
um
I think it's their seventh um successful
engine test on site in the last three
years over the course of the next couple
of months
and we've got high impulse doing engine
testing we've got a French company today
from Paris testing engines and Rocket
Factor you'll be doing their stage one
and two testing in July
um we've built our first ground stations
on Shetland and we're taking down data
as we speak
um so we're actually an operational
space port
um we've just secured a 139 million debt
facility from from the markets and which
will allow us to drive forward yes
there's a lot going on 80 employees as
well today from four
um six years ago very good and I think
it's the case that um you're privately
funded have you received any public
funds from any of the public bodies
that's a sore Point
um we've
um
thought and bit and scratched our way to
where we are now and to be fair to the
Space Agency just before Christmas we
secured a small Grant to build a launch
rail to support our suborbital launches
but all the all the monies we've spent
to date have been privately private
funds and it's the case that uh in the
in the Cornwall Spaceport and the
Sutherland Spaceport both of them have
had government grants of one form or
another all the other prospective
Spaceport suffered public sector funding
um it's a sore Point
um you know we've gone but what I would
point out is that you know we are very
close you know to to our first launch
we've you know we've created a Siege
mentality and it's been painful
um and you know there's always a balance
public sector funding can slow you down
um but unless you secure public sector
funding nobody believes that you're
actually real
um I wouldn't say no now you know what I
would throw out a challenge to
government is you match US pound per
pound and look at all the initiatives
that we're putting out there from our
steam
um our stem program for example I know
that's very close to to government
um two months ago we had a quarter of a
million children sign up to our online
stem lessons that's pretty cool seven
thousand from Liverpool alone from all
over the world and again we've probably
we've funded that privately
before I go to my colleagues just um
um tell us why shetlands you and not
Justin Shetland you're in the the
northernmost island of the of the
British Isles you know you're an
um I assume that there's a geographical
reason for that I'll let Dave answer
that in a minute but what I will say is
that space is about geography maths and
physics and the geography doesn't lie I
will also say that space book ends the
United Kingdom from Shetland in the
north to Cornwall in the South you know
when we've got a Spain of space activity
down the middle but I'll let my my
colleague answer that question tell us
why uh the the geography of Shetland is
significant
um there's two reasons
um when you break it down to the basics
the first one is the type of orbits that
we will be targeting with the launch
vehicles that we'll be using uh the
further north you are the better so nor
the latitude is good and the second
thing is we have
um a very clear area to launch into so
we are on the peninsula and the far
northeast corner of Ernst we'll be
looking to launch towards the North and
above us we have a large sea track so
from a safety point of view it's a very
safe place to launch those are the two
fundamental reasons why it's a good
place to launch thank you and obviously
as the the launch operations manager
you'll be having a close view of the of
the technology and a lot of its new
technology uh how confident are you that
it's it's ready is it ready or has it
got some some way to go before it's
ready for for deployment the technology
is is ready on the whole but obviously
each new launch Vehicle Manufacturer
comes along has a development process
that they need to get through so
um does the technology exist already
today to utilize our Spaceport yes but
we've also got new players approaching
us
good so my colleagues have got some
questions about the the licensing and
the regulatory process so we'll start
with Stephen Metcalfe thank you chair
and thanks for setting that up nicely
where are we with the licensing process
for the Spaceport right David answer
that one right my primary job at the
moment is working with Spaceport license
we are also actively pursuing a range
license
um our colleague Jimmy Slaughter is
running that he's not here today so I
will talk to the Spaceport license
um we submitted it through the CAA
portal in March of 22. we are currently
working through some rfis for that
um sorry you're working through some
some requests for support information
thank you um so we submitted the
documents we needed to submit and we're
going through iterations
um to answer questions from the CAE
so
um
the latest round of request information
we've got about half the stuff back to
them
um and
that's about it really that's probably a
good starting point okay and so you're
you're in this process
um presumably it's a relatively new
process
across the whole UK
um how are you finding that process and
when would you expect to receive a
license
right the process
um I think it's fair to say from our
perspective got off to a slow start
which was March last year
um
this is the first vertical launch
Facebook license in process and it's
definitely a learning process on both
sides
um for ourselves because we don't have a
metric
to compare ourselves to in the UK we
have other metrics around the world we
can compare ourselves to but in terms of
the UK regulations it's new
um so from my perspective I would say we
got off to a sleep start but we have a
very good relationship with the space
regulation team and we are progressing
the license well at the minute
in terms of when do I think the license
is going to come out I don't know the
answer to that I'll let Frank
take what he would like to have him yes
but in terms of when we will get a
license difficult question
I think the the country needs a licensed
vertical launch be sport sooner rather
than later it can have conditions and
you need checks and balances and as
David said it's new for both parties
but
there is every country in the world has
got a space economy and they all want to
be part of this space race and it's
moving very very quickly and if you look
at I mean I bang on about this but this
is how quickly Aid of space and space is
moving on the 17th of December 1903 was
the first man space man flight 68 years
later only 68 years later man walked on
the moon
on the 22nd of December 2022 up
announced we completed our first launch
pad that's 100 years it's moving very
quickly so we need to work with the
regulator to ensure and show the world
that we're open for business because
there's lots of young companies that
want to come here okay
um thank you for that and I I appreciate
um the points you've said about sooner
rather than later but in terms of is
this is not having a license in place
acting as a barrier yet
uh and when would you like to have a
license obviously as soon as possible
but realistically are you talking about
three months six months I I would like
to see a license in three months is that
thing as a body or no because we're
working on concurrent activity all the
time but that's because we're privately
funded and I've got to drive forward but
also
I think what this committee needs to
understand is that the industry is
moving so quickly and there's lots of
young companies out there that are
driving and they're all at a stage with
their r d and development that the water
is coming to the top of the dam and
they're all going to be looking to to to
build their businesses more or less
within six months to a year of each
other so we we need to be ready but we
need to be regulated and we need to be
safe because the last thing we need
things will go wrong and so we so so I
get this this balance so to answer your
question
um three months please a license in
three months won't hamper the business
longer than that it would start to have
an impact on our viability as a space
Nation I think so thank you and other
CAA apprised of the the needs to accom
to accommodate that timetable if it's
safe to do so yeah and the ca it's very
easy to beat the cea up and you know
we've been as David said we got on to it
on to uh you know to a slow start and
you know I'm the guy that had them up
against the wall if you
they understand you know but they've got
a job to do what if Government can give
them discretion so they we live in this
world where everyone's got to be and
it's a blame society as you guys and
ladies know me too well give them some
discretion but to work within the rules
but they're they're fully aware of the
requirement well I will say however
going back to your earlier statement
chairman is because all the other
spaceports are publicly funded a lot of
the
um launch companies have got large
tranches of public sector support
they're happy to just applaud along and
so you know the cea can only go along at
the pace of of what they're being asked
to do
um we're a bit different you know we're
in this new space economy and I think
and it's very difficult for a regulator
in the civil service department to start
to move at peace but but they are aware
and they're trying I've got to say it
they are trying
thank you
um so Graham Street has got some um
related questions I share my
ignorance I I Dave I didn't understand
why the launch has to be further north
there's more or less it's fair isn't it
why does it make any difference where
you launch from
has to do with the orbits that you can
access
um and the easiest way to explain that
is
um think of a a sky satellite dish on
the side of your house and it points
quite low down because it's pointing at
a satellite which is in an equatorial
orbit and the best place to launch those
is the traditional places like French
Guiana Cape Canaveral places that are
close to the equator
for a low earth orbit where the
satellite is much closer to the Earth
they run north south
so because of the spin of the Earth the
closer North you've got the less penalty
there is whereas for a
[Music]
equatorial launch you're making taking
advantage of the speed of rotation of
the Earth
so it's better it's physics
I think I'm closer to understanding it
thank you are the regulations for
spaceports separate from the regulations
for space flight
yes as in the the different
licenses that are available the ones
that we're concentrating on is the
Spaceport license and the range service
provisional license
then you need a launch operator's
license to do a launch you need a return
operator's license to bring something
back from orbit to Earth and then you've
got an on orbit license as well
right and are those regulations the two
separate sets of regulations are they
fit for purpose
okay it's one set of regulations that
covers everything
um
the
that's a difficult question
um are we working our way through them
and have we presented a a licensed
application to the CAA that meets the
requirements of the space industry
regulations I believe we have
um
could they be better probably but we
because of the time issue we've got to
work with what we have and I'm confident
that we can get our licenses
approved using the existing regulations
when we had previous Witnesses they told
us that
the regulations
would likely to stop investment
certainly in in Cornwall you don't think
there are hindrance to investment I
would suggest there were other agendas
from those Witnesses I saw some of the
um the regulations or the regulations
and are they fit for purpose
could they do with tweaking could they
do probably yes but this is the first
stop Cornwall got its license you know
if that's what we're alluding to they
got the range license the Technology
field not the Spaceport you know so and
it's important
um from our perspective it's about the
agility and the speed of getting to that
point
so that our clients can come in but I
can't see how that and and our clients I
said this I was in a meeting in
Whitehall two weeks ago
and I and I said to the to to the
politician go and talk to our clients
the the French company that are tasting
their engines they're two German clients
the Americans they're not coming to us
because we tell nice jokes and they want
to see Shetland ponies they're coming
because the UK is the right place to be
and we have something to offer there are
regulations everywhere there's
regulations in Germany the DLR you know
but we've got two German companies
testing engines in our Spaceport right
now
you know so it's very easy to hide
behind the regulations is how you
approach solving them and putting a team
in play we have a team of eight working
full-time on the on our licensing
process it costs money but most of them
unlike me or xrf pilots and and they're
working their way through it
I would not be doing my job properly if
I didn't ask you what the agendas were
I I well I'm not close enough to it but
if you look at what the outcome was and
looked as if that company was running
out of money and they were looking to
blame the government
for you know I just looked to me in the
outside looking in
the launch happened the technology
failed don't blame the licensor don't
blame the UK government for that they
got it away you know and you know if
you're not interest or get into into the
space industry you know manage the
messaging look what happened with um
SpaceX just recently how you know how
they manage that messaging brilliantly
we we know 80 of your first launches are
going to fail
but eventually your your Cadence will
build up and build up and and the
rockets will leave late buses you know
so just tell the truth
right you've been very positive about
the role of the CIA is the regulator
there must have been some difficulties
this is a new
uh
process about health and safety and
uh whatever being the biggest problems
I'll answer that one
feel free to start off
well from from at my level because
Dave's writing amongst the weeds
initially I think it's an understanding
of the of the marketplace
you know there's there's old space and
there's new space old space is the guys
with the blue suits and the white shirts
new spaces the 14 year old with a PhD
who's an international very bright young
man or woman and these other people are
in a hurry
um and I think this the ca came into
this from a standing start
and traditionally we've looked at the
baes and the boeings and all these big
aerospace companies trying to get under
the skin of these young companies who
have raised lots of money who are in a
hurry because remember it's all about
satellite technology it's all about the
mobile phone
um and I think you know it took time for
the ca to try to get under the skin of
the sector
um I I genuinely believe they're trying
now and you know some of them are behind
us here and you know as one of them
reminded me it was only three years ago
I had one of them up against the wall
saying you're not listening I genuinely
believe that they are listening
um the other thing is from the to be
fair to the CAA
there is I'm probably not allowed to
swear on television but there's so much
business there's so many smoking mirrors
um around this industry and I say it's
like you know if I ask I don't know if
you ski chairman but if I ask you do you
ski you'll see I've skied for 40 years
what you mean you've only skied for a
week a year for 40 years it's like men
playing golf
um and the space industry is full of
promises and the ca initially would have
listened to these companies saying we're
going to launch in the summer of 22.
we're going to launch in the in the
spring of 23 but they didn't really know
and so there's a learning process both
sides what I would counsel is that the
space industry is not new they've been
doing America for a long time safely
they've done it in Russia you know so
you know take the lessons learned from
those other
um space Nations and again the ca have
been working with the FAA and they've
actually helped us work with the FAA so
I never thought I'd say this three years
ago or after after three years but I
can't fault them I genuinely can't fault
them I can fault the lack of support
that we've had as a Spaceport you know
from government I can show the monies
that we've invested that we've got a
three-dimensional Spaceport that we're
doing all these initiatives around
um by ourselves but I can't fault the
regulator genuinely
um yeah I'll add a couple of comments um
from our point of view for the licensing
um we very deliberately have tried to
keep the licensing knowledge within our
company we're not Contracting it out
um so I think there's a there's large
amount of knowledge base in the UK
um that we need to build
um so we're trying to keep that within
our own company so we know you're going
forward when we need to change things
how to change things
um I think it's fair to see that from
the ca's point of view they're learning
as well the same way that we are and
it's it's building that knowledge base
and I think as we've started the
licensing process that knowledge base
hasn't been there probably as much as it
should be on either side
um so our plan is to keep that knowledge
in the company how the ca is managing
that I don't know but we are definitely
seeing uh more
[Music]
um
individuals on the teams that we're
engaging with on specific areas
and my hope would be that that knowledge
base is retained and expanded my last
question the process has got better I
think that would be a fair summary of
what uh what you're saying how could it
be improved further
uh for us speed
um it is difficult with the requests for
information
[Music]
on technical matters it takes time for
us to work those through give it back to
the CAA you let the cea work through it
and assess whether we've answered the
question that they asked
that's where it comes into the knowledge
base do we have people who can work that
quickly and do we have enough people
working on it and
it cuts both ways obviously we've got a
team we've split out the range team from
the Spaceport team to streamline that
internally
and certainly it's getting better as we
go along thank you thank you Graham you
both mentioned the the regulations
and so that they might be able to be
tweaked obviously these regulations will
put in anticipation of launch in the UK
and it would be pretty likely that in
practice you discover things that you
wish you'd known at the time are there
any particular respects that you think
the regulations you know without
criticizing them in anticipation you
didn't capture what you're now
experiencing
I'll let Dave answer that the one thing
I would say is that when the regular in
this is in our opinion when the
regulations were first crafted they
weren't expecting a Spaceport up in the
north of Shetland to have a multi-use
site and the regulations were probably
crafted looking at a one user one pad
Spaceport and I think this had to be
some adjustment there
um no that I think summarizes it at best
um
we that's where we run into difficulties
um trying to explain our concept of
operations because we have a good launch
site we have a lot of available
um
trajectories where the launch Vehicles
can go
so building the safety case for that is
quite difficult and I don't think the
regs necessarily help us with that but I
think that's the single biggest
overarching comment
um the
is that
and this this aligns to regulation and
this is not the criticism that this is
just fact and if you go on the website
you know tied to regulations the
commercial viability of that business
okay so the Cornwall Spaceport is
licensed for two lunches a year with one
one user now that user fails sadly it
did and we were rooting for Cornwall to
to succeed two launches a year doesn't
make for a commercial space board it
just can't it just doesn't and if that
end user fails then you've neutered your
Spaceport you've got to look at what
will make that Spaceport sustainable
I have an obligation not just to
shareholders but to communities and to
the country to make sure that you know
we are that we're we're a viable
Spaceport 30 years from now I get
letters from eight-year-old girls
looking for jobs in space such is the
interest in in the economy so allowing
the regulation to the commercial
viability of the Spaceport and then
you've got a long-term industry don't
look for one one hit wonders
thank you
and we've mentioned the few times this
morning the lack of funding or lack of
Public Funding could you give us some
reasons why you have been unsuccessful
in that well well both governments and
both Scottish and and we came to the
party Elite you know there was a um I I
you haven't got time for the whole story
you need to read the book and we are
doing a Netflix series
um we weren't taken seriously government
was looking at publicly funded sites
um in the UK
um and
um we came in two years later what I
would say is that we got our planning
permission a year ago two years after
another site and we're almost finished
um so I just didn't think we were taken
seriously and shetlands out there that
the Shetland economy is based on its
geography as you know oil and gas
Renewables aquaculture fishing now space
and I just don't think anyone took us
seriously and as Government When
government goes down it's like a super
tanker when it goes down a line to shift
that super tanker it takes a lot
um had we got the Public Funding we'd be
ready now
trust me
um and we are well I'd like to invite
the whole committee to come up and visit
you know I think you know a picture you
know what I say is use us as the
Exemplar back success because if we're
successful up there the rest will filter
all the way back down and then if you
again if you get Cornwall working we can
meet in the middle but we've got a lot
going on so I I there's a lot happy to
talk offline
um
I mean I remember a number of years ago
there was a problem in a
MSP it's a touri MSP no Continuum but he
talked about Scotland's Ambitions in
space being science fiction which went
across the the front page of the the
papers and it caused quite a lot of
upset do you think part of the issue is
that people still don't look at the UK
as a viable player here you know you fit
the nail on the head I I don't remember
I never saw that one otherwise I'd be
with you shouting Okay so we've got a
pilot here my background's in physical
education you know if somebody had
taught me and told me in 1976 when I
went to the Scottish School of PE or
1983 when I went to the Royal Air Force
College Cromwell I'd be building a
Spaceport on Shetland I'd said you know
you're smoking rope you know I mean what
am I doing building a Spaceport and when
we started this journey five years ago
um my colleague Scott who spoke to you
the last time we really didn't
understand we genuinely didn't
understand we know a lot about Aviation
and defense and as we've walked the
streets of Europe and and America and
let these 17 year olds with phds and
getting the letters from the young kids
worked with the high impulses of this
world and the rfas we've realized the
size of this economy and it to me
genuinely it's like a new Industrial
Revolution but I think you're absolutely
right people didn't believe and
sometimes up there in Shetland when I
briefed the Shetland Island Council
four years ago I started off by saying
this is not an April Fool right and
because we just didn't know but now you
know you need to understand we're not
selling ourselves to these companies
that are coming to us they're coming
because the geography the maths in the
physics works and in Scotland Scotland
has the ability to be a genuine space
Nation but the UK you know you know
somebody asked me a couple of weeks ago
where do we sit in the league table I
think we're halfway up the championship
we're not in the Premier League we have
the ability
you know if you look at what's going on
with our education system and our
manufacturers certainly in central belt
Scotland and in Surrey to be in the
Premier League but we need to we know we
really need to move quickly and
aggressively but we can't so I agree
with you
there is no financially viable what are
you looking at we're at 30. you know so
our our license application is for 30
launches
um at the moment weekly that's it's
virtually yeah will it be season
dependent will there be more in the
summer that's another very good question
so as you will be well aware shetland's
way up there in the north and
um we got 10 years worth of data on
um on on the winds for example in
Shetland and
um to launch you need three hours of 30
knots or less of wind in the from the
month from the spring to the Autumn
Believe It or Not 95 of days have three
hours could be three in the morning of
course of of um of suitable winds and in
the winter it's one day in three so
um so yeah we can achieve that if again
during it based on the discussions we're
having with our clients I think
eventually we'll be going back into the
CAA to get an extension to 40 or 50
slots
but again Carl it's very important we're
not wholly relying to launch we're
bringing down data and we've also got a
tourism element to what we're doing as
well so if for some reason launch is
delayed we've got revenues coming in
from elsewhere I mean I think certainly
some members of the committee would be
very keen to take you up in your offer
to see it and I think it would be it
would be useful for us to kind of see
what's going on in the site can you tell
me how many companies you're planning to
be working with on your 30 lunches a
year well today
um I was talking to the city earlier we
are Launchpad one is gone it's
contracted to a German company called
Rocket Park drugs that's for their um
we've got high impulse so we've got nine
International companies that we're
working with on ground on on launch and
we're working with three on data
so and they've all come to us I stress
and they're from Germany France Italy
India turkey
on America obviously
thank you thank you moving on a couple
of questions just about a support just
is there anything else that the ca or
the government could be doing in order
to support the industry
you want to talk about regulation on
that and I was talking about
I think we've kind of already talked the
regulation piece through um I don't
think I've got anything more to add to
that
I think the problem that government has
is you need to spread your net wide
you've got to be seen to be company
agnostic I would say you need to start
backing winners because of the winners
win the race will spread out I think
they're trying to be all things to all
men and it's not quite working
and sometimes you know government tries
to put projects in places
um for political reasons rather than for
practical reasons and I think they just
need to change but you know if you look
at you know our education you know stem
has been promoted big time we're looking
at climate change we're looking to build
a space environmental climate control
center up in Shetland so can we use that
data you know well we're you know so I
think all the government initiatives are
there maybe what you should look at and
I never thought I'd say this is if it
was me there's too many organizations
there's too many membership
organizations I would be appointing
let's call it a space SAR but not
somebody with a usual DNA from the same
gene pool somebody that understands new
space old space defense the
internationalism of it somebody who
understands the way the Civil the the
regulations work pull it together
because we've got you know as I say the
waves coming up on the UK and we're in a
great place but if we're not careful we
will you know we will lose out you know
I was actually just about to ask you one
of the piece of evidence we heard that
our last session was that sometimes
there's too many different things and
people don't quite know there's it seems
to be a lack of coordination across that
I agree so um yeah so some sort of
portal that people can go where
regulations are understood where
licenses understood that would make
things yes it's the short answer today
um we've talked a lot about Rigs and
we've talked about licenses but those
are any of the licenses that are
required on under the Space Industries
act there are also other licenses and
Marine licenses Etc et cetera so for us
to encourage people to come along from
us you've got to make it simpler it's
quite complicated with the number of
bodies that have to be engaged
complicated for you because you're
having to learn about all these
different
um agencies is it difficult for the
agencies as well to work with each other
yes because we're new and I'll throw an
example out there for example coma
um you know it exists for
um control of major accident hazards so
a major industrial facility is like a
petroleum facility or something we will
come under that because of the
quantities and materials we're going to
have on the site but no one's ever done
that before for a Spaceport in the UK so
once we've got it done it'll be done
that's great and that's not something
that a potential customer would deal
with but for a customer coming to us we
go yeah you need to get a SAE license
they go that's great how do we do it but
there's all these other things that have
to go with it and I think that's where
it needs to be a bit more joined up
just to complete the picture on the CAA
you've as Graham says you've given a a
positive review of your experience of
them improving over time one of the
things that we heard was that
establishing space within the CAA was
going to be dominated by the civil
aviation
um and they may not have enough people
have you what's your experience in terms
of the the attention you've had from
from individuals have you had to kind of
wait in the queue or do you think
they've got enough resource
um
as I said earlier we got off to a slow
start
um
from our perspective it did feel like
stuff was going into the CA and not
coming back
some of that is due to the licensing
process because it's very much a to get
from the initial Screen through to the
assessment phase the processor setup
that everything has to go at the same
time
so for example we ended up with one
particular area that we had to revisit
several times all the other stuff that
was ready from our perspective wasn't
being assessed now whether it could have
been
assessed at that time I don't know
so from the outside
the process is slow to get going part of
that is the way the process is set up
whether that's also due to Resource is
within the ca I don't know certainly at
the moment my engagement directly with
the teams within the CAA I'm seeing more
people there so from my perspective I am
seeing more resources on the CAA side
and at the moment we seem to be ticking
along quite nicely okay fingertips time
to build that resource and then coming
back to the speed of movement of this
industry I suspect within the CAA they
didn't realize how fast this sector was
going to move and how important it would
be
again I'm trying to be fair
being cynical I would also say that
probably a lot of that resource was
pointed towards Cornwall quite rightly
to get that away but I would also point
out that the starts the FAA only 10 of
launches will be horizontal the other 90
percent will be vertical to ourselves
and orbits and in Sutherland
Etc so how does the ca manage that
resource but it takes time to find them
to get them trained up and I keep saying
we're we're in a hurry you know because
we have to be under system sometimes
can't move that quickly but you know
it's probably sound because they're
behind us just now with guns pointed at
us that we're being nice about them but
trust me you know we're being very you
know we're being pretty pragmatic I I we
have no issues at the moment
thank you and just finally we mentioned
you've made an interesting
recommendation that there should be a
space and satellite Tsar to kind of all
everything together
in the absence of that there is a UK
government National Space strategy that
was published in September 2021 is that
a document that um that you engage with
it is does it is it a helpful thing do
is it meaningful to you
no right because I still think going
back to fit for purpose you know it's
like when the consultation went out
before for the regulations we all not
just as but everyone inputed but none of
our recommendations were accepted
um which was a very poor starting point
I keep coming back to this industry is
about the high impulses the rfas the
orbixes the these young companies coming
through you know I mean you've all got
your mobile phones in front of you it's
all about satellite technology the
mobile phone is the sixth kind of the
21st century it controls our lives but
it changes you you know you change your
phone every couple of years so you know
so our Space strategy
um needs to move with the times however
again with the sad state of affairs with
you know the world order has changed you
know the Ukraine has changed a lot of
you know a lot of people's attitudes to
space the future Wars are going to be
unfortunately are going to be up there
in space everything needs to be pulled
together and I would say take a more
holistic overview of space but go back
to the young people I'm 65 I was 65 last
week what am I doing here building a
Spaceport is because these young people
are driving us and and trust me chairman
I wouldn't be I wouldn't have come all
the way from Scotland today I would I
mean we've spent 27 million pounds in a
year building a Spaceport I wouldn't be
doing that unless we believed in this
sector well certainly you do and we're
grateful that you've both of you made
the journey from Shetland to join us
today so can I thank Strang Ms balance
for your evidence today and I'm going to
introduce the next panel of witnesses
I'm sure come and see us yes please
thank you I think um
[Laughter]
so let me invite our next pair of
witnesses and they are Dr Mario kobold
who is the Chief Executive Officer of
high impulse Technologies uh who have
been referred to already high impulse
are a German company that's developing a
small launch system for small satellites
welcome and thank you
do we have the labels for our Witnesses
sorry and Jonas spiano who is appearing
virtually uh I think if the screen there
we are in perfect time Mr bianu is the
chief technology officer of orbex which
is developing a low-carbon orbital micro
launch system
and is intended to make use of the
proposed Sutherland Spaceport
and Mr biano worked previously at
Denmark's National Space Institute thank
you very much indeed both of you for
joining us uh today perhaps I could just
ask with a basic question perhaps
starting with Dr cobbled if you describe
what's your what Your Business does what
your technology does and and how close
it is to uh to fruition
yeah well thank you for having me today
um so high impulse is a new space
startup we've been founded in 2018 in
Germany and we are working on sounding
rockets and small launchers which is
based on our special technology that we
are using which is called hybrid rocket
propulsion and this gives us some nice
competitive advantages and we've been
demonstrating the technology the
founders of heimples already as students
and now we are working on
preparing for the first launch actually
this year so
testing Rocket Motors in general is not
not easy from regulation and also from
the whole operation itself and we had
actually difficulties doing this in
Germany at Large Scale so that's uh when
we when we have met actually the
colleagues from saxophot already two or
three years ago and we've been looking
for a possibility to do engine testing
but also of course looking for a future
alongside so that's when our
collaboration started and they enabled
us to
start doing our test campaigns in
Shetland Islands and since then in the
last two years or so we have done
already eight test campaigns for the
development of our Rocket motors and now
just some weeks ago in April we had the
last successful Campaign which basically
now
um
shows that the technology is fully ready
to do a first launch together with sex
afford actually this October
what made you attracted to uh to the UK
and and Shetland in particular
presumably you looked at other places
before uh deciding on Shetland yeah I
think it was explained already a bit
before of course there is uh just
technical restrictions on the place
where you can launch so in Europe
actually there's not so many places
there's some other launch sites for us
for example in Sweden or Norway but then
uh in UK basically from the technical
requirements also Shetland Islands is
the best place for from from a
geographical point of view also and um
also the collaboration together with
saxophone has been pretty nice all the
time and they operate also like us as a
startup and try to move and get things
done and work efficiently and that's an
important point to to succeed also thank
you let me turn to our other witness
um and I didn't introduce him as a
doctor bear nobody I understand that um
not surprisingly in this sector he's
also a PhD so Dr biano
um tell us a bit about your company and
why you've chosen Sutherland as the uh
as the place to Target launch
yes thank you very much also for having
me today so uh orbix is probably best
described as a combination of the two
witnesses you've just heard evidence
from so basically orbix is an end-to-end
solution uh delivering both a launch
vehicle and a Spaceport solution to
facilitate operations of that launch
vehicle
we were founded in 2016 and
we went at the problem to develop a
clean sheet type launch system so we had
the opportunity to choose Solutions
freely with nowhere priority commitments
to technology
and for that reason we ended up with a
system that is fully propelled by a
green propellant so a biopellant quite
uniquely in this sector
um
and we found
essentially a system solution that
enabled us to operate that from a a very
minimalistic Spaceport located uh in in
the highlands region and yeah also near
the silent uh online peninsula
uh as to your question as why we chose
that the specific location really our
journey started quite early in 2016 and
at that point in time we looked at
various options for launch uh in Europe
there were not many to choose from
basically at that stage we only had Peru
in South South America as an option and
S Ranson and I had aspirational thoughts
but beyond that there weren't really any
and we were looking of course you are
trading a lot of different metrics but
our system is a so-called micro launcher
and one of the important metrics there
is proximity so physically having your
systems located closely to each other
your Test Facilities your production
facilities your launching operations
facilities
simply as a cost saving measure and
therefore a way to build a sustainable
business case and then the real game
changer for us came with the combination
of the space industry act in 2018 and
then the launch UK program initiation
around that point in time which enabled
us together with Highland Styles
Enterprise and Lockheed Martin at that
time to field April a combined proposal
for the silent Spaceport and for us to
set up a permanent presence in the UK
thank you uh on that so you've chosen
Sutherland when do you expect
construction of the the Spaceport at
Sutherland to be to be complete
so we have in fact Broken Ground in
Sutherland just earlier this month uh
this project is a 10-month effort to
field the initial capability and then we
would be moving our launch Furniture so
to speak onto the launch site in the
period that follows this so we should
achieve an operational capability second
half of 2024.
I'm going to turn to my colleagues for
some questions starting with uh Dawn
Butler and then Stephen Metcalf into
chair
um uh Dr Brown no
um thank you very much it sounds really
great that you've got this low carbon
launch system I don't know what that
means
um but but it sounds
um it sounds futuristic uh I just wonder
um when do you expect Sutherland
Spaceport to receive its uh Spaceport
license
so at this point in time we are working
very closely to uh together with the CAA
to prepare our license application here
for and then we will expect that to pass
through uh CAA with with the Cadence
that they currently project to be on the
order of a year
so our submission is currently due for
June and then the license issuance uh
about a year from there and actually
that is subject to uh to to uh to the
application flow
you don't see any issues or problems
with that license at all you think
that'll be quite straightforward
so uh we we put in our launch vehicle
license application uh in February last
year
and of course we being a a an end-to-end
solution have to cater to both the
launch service provider license and the
launch site operators license so both
facets of it and and this has been a
good process so far together with with
the CAA we expect the same level of
collaboration that we've had with them
to uh to continue
um
and of course I mean all of this will be
guided by the safety case and the
analysis that goes into this so I I mean
an engineer by art so I don't expect
anything to be Problem free ever but uh
I mean I I would expect this to be a the
simpler of the two applications that we
have to cater to if I can put it like
that thank you and just um with the CAA
uh how does your relationship or your
experience with them differ from other
Regulatory Agencies
well I mean we can say that that obix
really or from the UK side engages
primarily with with with the cas the
regulatory body uh I will say initially
uh when we started the process on the
launch license application for the
vehicle back a year ago we were off to a
somewhat slow start and a somewhat
sluggish interaction with them this has
picked up tremendously over the course
of the last
uh seven eight nine months and we are
now on a on a regular meeting Cadence
with and we have face to face meetings
on a regular basis they are side
visiting us or we had a side visit three
weeks ago we have a follow-up meeting
today so so overall I think we have a I
mean a solid working relationship
um and um and a good I mean very
competent technical engagement with them
I find thank you and to both of you just
lastly um
just as our understanding of the CAA do
you think there's anything more that
they could do would you like them to
work in a different way
is there anything that you'd like to add
around that
um
sorry yes
um I mean we clearly see that the uh the
licensing process is developing uh we
wouldn't expect anything else we always
viewed this as a uh it's at a set
between them and us because we are
developing a vehicle and they're
developing a process for for uh for
issuing a licensed toward that vehicle
in at the same time so
there are elements where
um
we've seen some discrepancy between what
was required by the regulation and what
was in Egypt by the CAA to to implement
that and we have had some issues with
Clarity in that regard they have been
able to provide that as we as we go
along as as the engagement has matured
so I think the the the key issue for us
is always the time it takes for a
feedback loop the time it takes for an
engagement so the the more the quicker
we are able to turn around questions and
answers the basically the quicker we are
able to progress to a solid
implementation of the of the license
and this is really our desire we I mean
we're a startup uh just as the other
elements on your panel so we are very
time conscious as to anything that we do
thank you very much and Mr capalda to
YouTube the CIA is there anything that
you think that you would like them to uh
do differently
um yeah maybe first of all I think the
interactions have been uh very positive
overall and they have also been open to
feedback that we have provided them and
that they also implemented
um maybe a general introduction we have
a sub-orbital flight license pending
currently with the CAA under the ano and
the second suborbital flight
and future orbital flan flights are
planned under the CIA so
um
the the process has taken quite a bit of
time under the ano license which we have
been told that it would work actually
faster than the CIA and we
um
um I think it's clear that it's a new
topic also for CAA and they approach
um
the safety margins for example probably
more conservative than if FAA and
um
great brilliant thank you so much thank
you thank you chair Stephen Metcalf
thank you
um Chad so
um it's clear the ambition of the UK is
to be a successful
space Nation
um there's a lot of activity going on
but we heard in our last session that
there is
potentially the need for more
coordination and
more sense of purpose and Direction and
urgency the idea of a space SAR was
floated
there was discussion about creating a
single point of contact for licensing
and applications what are your views on
that what interventions what more can
the UK do whether it's the CAA the
government other government agencies do
to help us meet our ambitions
um I would say probably the most
important part would be uh to be
flexible to adapt the airspace uh for
for launching So currently for us it
looks like there are very short launch
Windows possible due to the airspace
change progress and these windows also
expire after a short period
and it can take time to prepare a launch
and there can be also
some minor technical delays which will
introduce a waiting time
or also we have to wait for acceptable
weather conditions and then if the
window passes or expires during a delay
we need to go around again and then this
is a huge cost and also an unnecessary
further delay
um yeah okay thank you
Dr biano
I would say from from our perspective I
mean the the point of contact for
licensing uh or single point of entry uh
in into not only the CAA parts of
Licensing but also I mean airspace and
Marine
licensing it would be a sensible
implementation or sensible suggestion
uh further to your point on on uh on the
uh invoking the strategy in this the I
mean the German space are uh I think
from our perspective
we we tend to look at these things a
little uh more holistically possible
um
it's it's about the UK making the most
of the effort deployed here if I can put
it in in those terms uh we we feel very
strongly that the the point of us being
in in the UK is not just to to come in
and execute a launch and then I mean
then leave again it's the wider
socio-economic impacts that that we can
generate locally also from from being
present in the UK and uh and and it goes
I mean far uh and and wide in terms of
what those impacts are uh so we're
locally
in the forest just outside in Vanessa
and we picked that location for a number
of reasons specifically because you have
proximity to uh to test sites you have
proximity to strong
industry Partners you have proximity to
the launch side eventually and you have
the entire benefit of the UK supply
chain that we are leveraging very
heavily uh so these deeper benefits you
only really
gain those by the implementation of a
sovereign capability if we can put it
like that
and and this is where we we see our our
role in in the UK space side really
coming coming uh full circle is that we
are able to provide this end-to-end
capability that also
should I mean will serve to increase uh
the capability of of the um of The Wider
community
I mean stimulates been off stimulate
startups and and other if about
thank you and I suppose one last final
question if I may which is the purpose
of these sessions is to gather evidence
and to make ultimate recommendations to
government is there any one single thing
that you would like to be front and
center
in our report back to government that
they can try and address
yes I mean if I I can add at least one
point that I think is is critical also
for from our perspective in in and again
I'm gonna refer to this vertical
integration uh situation that we've we
face and that is very much related to
the uh the talent pool in the UK so we
we are very uh strictly trying to
acquire UK engineering based UK
technicians in the UK staff wherever
it's practical and possible and and
preferably local stuff uh but but we
also do face limitations in certain
areas uh specifically related to launch
vehicle development and propulsion
systems which is not something that the
UK has pursued for many years
and then we are forced to bring in that
type of head count from abroad
and actually that comes with an overhead
on on Visa uh fees that is considerable
but also it it doesn't give the full
benefit of what we could be doing in the
UK so from my perspective one thing to
bring forward is that
initiatives to stimulate a university
level graduates or Aerospace technician
uh
development in this sector would go a
long way
you have to appreciate the position that
the the Public Funding made available
here is being geared quite heavily at
least in our case with private funding
more than a one to five ratio and we are
I mean moving a lot of people in to the
sector but we have to bring them out of
of other sectors so to to be able to
sustain growth and develop a sustainable
capability long term we need we need
more Talent
brilliant thank you uh Mr Cobalt do you
want to add anything to that
um yeah I think so the UK sa overall has
been very encouraging and there are a
lot of initiatives
that are positive for UK launch industry
and also I think it's notable that UK
National Space strategy
launcher is currently in number one in
the 10 point plan which is also
encouraging for us
I am
I also wanted to mention before actually
that high impulse also has a UK
subsidiary which we established
I think also two years ago already which
is basically involved in the testing and
also we have
an office space in Edinburgh with
Engineers working there
and then maybe back to uksa
um and there's the space flight phase
two
plan which would procure launches and
and payloads for from small launchers
and uh so this would help on the one
hand the satellite industry to
build build satellites and plan launches
and also give some incentive for the
launch providers like us to to do the
launches and um
I think last December this program was
put on on some some hold and it would be
good to to continue this and
then it would be also helpful of course
to to establish UK's uh future role in
in the space in the new space Indus
industry AS Global player
and um
yeah I think that concludes excellent
thank you Tracy is coming
to follow up
um what Dr brianno said about the talent
pool I wonder given you you have a UK
subsidiary do you have any comments or
views on the talent pool that is
available to you and what more perhaps
we need to do to encourage
um you know the expansion of that pool
yeah I think that there is uh quite
quite some Talent available so uh for us
I can say we are an international
company we have a lot of different
employees from all over Europe but also
some International employees and we've
been we've also uh of course employees
from the UK and our
uh employees work in Edinburgh are also
locally there so
um overall I think this new space
movement basically is also a good
advertisement and the satellite launches
and all the infrastructure around the
Frank Strang mentioned before that and
there will also be tourism that will
um will be
allowed to take part in the launch
campaigns so it's a
interesting from that point and also of
course it's uh it's a high-tech area
that we are working in which is I think
attractive for for many many young
people and this will
help grow further the the
um
new students to go into this steam Steam
studies also
do you have any challenges with visas or
anything for the
for talent coming here a smile are there
any sort of kind of immigration or VISA
issues for your staff your International
staff yeah it's uh sometimes a long
process yeah but so we have the minister
coming on later it can all the potential
area that we could explore with the
minister
yeah it's a long process is it
is it a reliably successful people come
out at the other end or do you are you
frustrated that um you don't get the
people that you need to have for your
operation
um no I think we can get the people but
they are like it was mentioned for some
Internationals the Visa process can take
some time but this is actually what we
experience also in Germany and uh yeah
it's uh
oh
can I just ask a final question to uh Dr
biano building on something that Dawn
Butler asked at the beginning you talk
about a low carbon uh launch model for
orbex now we don't think of space launch
as being you know particularly
environmentally
sound in terms of the the fuel that's
consumed tell us a bit about the the low
carbon aspect and and how it Compares
with other launch systems
yes the interesting element is that it
doesn't really compare to other launch
systems because basically most of the
existing systems use either solid fuels
or kerosene-based fuels or or or in
extreme cases also inoxic fuels and and
all of these creates emissions when they
are burned and those emissions are put
in the atmosphere and and essentially
create what's known as the carbon
umbrella and and will have detrimental
effects on the environment but it's
wider in the sense that it it's also it
also makes our ground operations
relatively benign so ours is a
biopropane meaning it's fully Road
transportable it's easy to store if you
spill it it doesn't seep into the ground
and create hazards or contamination over
time uh and and all in all you end up
with a vehicle that becomes
operationally very versatile but also
has a very benign carbon footprint both
in its creation and in its operation and
that we don't really see many of those
are out and about in the industry and it
we also see it as a commercial
differentiator and we see customers
picking up on that element very well
mainly because of the the ongoing clean
space initiatives that sort of I mean it
in the infancy across the European space
agency and and other agencies across the
world but it is it's the direction in
which the world is moving and we were
just fortunate to pick a solution that
allowed us to move first
okay um thank you very much Lee it's
been very useful to hear from uh to the
companies involved so thank you Dr biano
and thank you Dr Cobble for your
evidence today we're now going to move
on to our third panel of witnesses
and joining us in the committee room is
Colin McLeod who is the head of space
regulation for the civil aviation
Authority the CAA it's been referred to
much this morning already and joining us
virtually
um I hope we have Rob bishton who is the
joint chief executive of the CAA
uh and just in time we have Mr Bishop
thank you very much indeed for uh for
joining us today thank you uh both uh
you'll have heard uh I'm sure the uh the
evidence that that we've heard this
morning and also in our previous uh
session uh and you've obviously got
pretty good reviews from the uh from the
witnesses uh this morning uh but also uh
perhaps a a bit of a a bit of a
challenge
um we um we heard evidence from Mr
Strang that uh it's very important that
their license is available uh within a
few months I think three months uh he
said
um
starting with Mr bishnan is is that a
realistic time frame for them to be
aspiring to
well good morning chair members of the
committee and thank you very much for
allowing the opportunity to talk to you
today uh representing the CA and my role
as the interim joints at
chief executive I'm actually in Glasgow
today at a board meeting so apologies I
couldn't be there with you
um but yesterday having come up to
Scotland I met with the Scottish
transport Minister space was on the
agenda so to Mrs moynihan's reference to
previous newspaper articles definitely
not science fiction definitely about
scientists and innovators and throughout
the UK and in and in Scotland I met with
Sky Aura yesterday afternoon in their
test facility as well and they were able
to describe to me the
um progress that they're making and also
the connections to Academia up here in
Scotland to various academic organ
institutions so I think a really
positive uh trip for us as a board to
Scotland on Space
um I think the reference references and
and feedback you've received from
witnesses to date shows that the ca has
listened uh made a lot of progress and
is still looking to make Improvement
about the regulatory process clearly
um to your question uh the point comes
back to that of speed
um and the uh the basis of of obviously
progress when it comes to speed is
largely around you know the
understanding
um of the regulatory process and we've
spent a lot of time making sure that we
are better able to describe that for
applicants so that submissions are dealt
with in a timely manner
um clearly there's a lot of reference
made to the speed in other regulatory
jurisdictions but we have to look at
national interests we have to look at
National Security we have to look at
Ground Hazard airspace and environment
very much through the UK lens as you
would expect I'm sure the regulator uh
too so Colin might be able to uh comment
specifically on the state of progress
regards to Mr strang's organization's
application but I think his
feedback Mr balance's feedback and those
of other Witnesses today has been very
balanced very fair we accept the
challenges and indeed some of the areas
where it's been indicated Improvement
could be made for instance the
coordination role across numerous
agencies when it comes to these
applications but today you know we we
feel we're aligned with the aligning
with the 10 key points in the UK's
strategy to make sure that the UK is
open for business to Mr Strong's a very
clear point and that progress
it's a date since 21 July 21 when we
took over this role we have 343 licenses
now approved we have 763 British
satellites
um in low orbit constellation which is
the second biggest constellation of
satellites the one web satellite
constellation we've got 25 active
applications uh in progress in the UK so
I think uh chair and hopefully members
of the committee
um referencing previous discussions
we've shown that we've responded to a
lot of that challenge
um and we we've taken on board the
current challenges that are being tabled
by I think an industry now that is very
very good at art
articulating what it needs and hopefully
a regulator that's clearly attuned to
listening to that okay thank you uh for
that we can hear it clearly but you're a
little thing so I'm going to ask you for
our technical colleagues can turn up the
volume in the room uh uh a bit
um but to to Mr McLeod um you you heard
the evidence in the in the previous
session and there's seems to be good
engagement uh between the the partners
but obviously part of that is having
coordinating your expectations in terms
of time frames and if people are
operating to a completely different
expectation than you think is realistic
that is not very productive so what's
your response to the suggestion from Mr
strong that actually a three-month or so
license window is what they uh what they
need
thank you chair and thank you committee
and thanks to the previous speakers it's
very good to hear the feedback and uh as
Rob said we have been developing and
changing how we approach things and I
think the evidence from previous
speakers has also indicated that
hopefully we're on a an upward
trajectory of of improvement across all
of these activities
I think in terms of timing there's a few
aspects there which are worth bringing
to the tension committee that the first
is that in the time that we've been the
regulator we actually haven't caused any
delay to any space operations whether it
launch or satellite since we started and
indeed from Rob's comment there we've
actually signed off another two licenses
yesterday so we're now at 345 licenses
that's not to say we don't want to to
make them better and improve the pace
uh Frank earlier mentioned also some of
the the Ambitions or the time skills
that industry put forward sometimes the
Pub the public deadlines or public
announcements for launch can be well
ahead of when they actually really are
technically ready and even in the last
six weeks we've seen four significant
failures in in Space the SpaceX one is
very high profile we also saw a rocket
from Sweden that was launched and
accidentally landed in Norway and we saw
a new rocket in America from relativity
space also have anomaly in its first
launch 90 of first launches are failing
still that just shows how incredibly
difficult this is and
to add to the complexity of this from
this from the evidence we've heard today
including last time with Virgin you've
talked to three different rocket
manufacturers one uses jet fuel and not
liquid oxygen one uses solid fuel and
one uses a new eco-friendly fuel they
all have different navigation systems
different engines different propulsions
so they're all very difficult and
complicated things
but in terms of the application for
saxophone
it's not right for us to talk in detail
about what their application is or where
it is at the moment but we don't foresee
a particular problem as we sit here
today or being able to launch that
license that in the summer assuming all
the tests can be met and again that
would be ahead of the Readiness of of
the rockets and what we're trying to do
in the ca is also balance the
requirements of all the applications
that we have
so for example in the last week we've
just managed to license in a very short
space of time uh
a very experienced UK satellite
manufacturer who had the their deadlines
shifted by their launch Company by six
to eight weeks unexpectedly
we were able to move things around to
meet that
which caused some pauses in some other
applications but it's not stopping the
actual operations or the technical
Readiness of those of those um companies
we'll take some questions from uh
colleagues but I think it's um it's
worth putting a record that you perform
a very important regulatory role and
this committee uh where you were a
launched to to fail in a way that was a
result of a of a failure of Regulation
would have some very severe questions
and we know that you have to balance
that against the understandable sense of
urgency that commercial companies and
indeed the public have for launch and we
we very much respect that and I don't
think we would expect you to to make
specific commitments on time scales
about a particular application but we've
we've heard Mr Strong's aspirations on
that let me go to Aaron Bell first and
then Chris Clarkson thank you chair so
thank you both
um could we just go back to the Cornwall
Spaceport failed launch again I know we
had uh sir Stephen Hillier and Tim
Johnson from you in the session the
first of March and there was quite a bit
of follow-up from other Witnesses
yourselves and so on in writing to the
committee after that can you provide us
any further updates on the lessons
learning activities that have taken
place at the CAA since the failed launch
I don't mind which of you answers that
who's best place to do that
I'm happy to start chair if that's okay
thank you
thank you um I know you can hear me a
little bit more clearly now
um look I think that particular uh event
the scenario leading up to it and
provided a lot of learning opportunities
um for us as the regulator particularly
in terms of Engagement and particularly
when you have an organization that is
used to want regulatory regime but
obviously has to then submit an
application to fit in with a different
regulatory regime and as I touched upon
there are things
things that you can't take a credit for
uh no matter what your collaboration is
um in this case with the FAA as a
regulator so I think we did maximize
um the knowledge and information
exchange with the FAA I do think that
there were things that were specifically
uh to be looked at by us as the
regulator for the UK through that
National lens as I said you know
National Security interest issues ground
Hazard particularly with the Cornwall
launch as you can imagine that was a
very very different
um set of of situations that had to be
assessed by the team and clearly our
space
um there was a lot of of interactions
with Portugal
um Ireland and indeed Spain and I'm
making sure that the uh the airspace
aspects were managed and the maritime
aspects and I do think that we've got to
recognize that whilst we've got a
dedicated space team
in ca48 we did actually enroll
well most of the rest of the
organization I mean one of the learnings
for the CAA is that with a particularly
complex activity that is a singular
activity to Mr Strong's Point
um it does consume a lot of the
organization so one of the learnings for
us was how do we balance off the broader
sector
um interests and and those interests of
other applicants so that was a
definitely a key learning but trying to
simplify and clarify through engagement
what we expect in our regulation regime
I don't think the question was around
actually should be the fitness and
purpose of the space act or the
framework we're working within it is
more around the understanding of the
applicant and indeed our team's approach
to processing those applications I do
think we also learned a lot about
precedence as in where you set
conditions within licensing so the
conditions precedence that you you set
within licensing I think we've learned
for particularly complex
operations
you can still move to approve the
license that doesn't necessarily mean
launch but what it does is it means the
regular
regulatory process has been complete and
you place then the owners back on the
organization into case virgin orbit
Cornwall Spaceport and you ask them you
know you monitor them in in their
undertaking then a post licensing so I
think there was a lot of learnings
around that and I think another point
we learned from which came out from
previous Witnesses today was the
coordination across you know multiple
agencies HSC UK space agency ofcom
environmental Maritime office of nuclear
regulation I could I could go on and
click there's a key opportunity for us
all within this system now to make sure
that that coordination role whether it's
with the CAA or not but it's clarified
um for the sake of applicants and for
ultimately uh speed of decision making
and Colin may wish to build thank you Mr
Bishop you said that you have learned
lessons about resourcing essentially
about the needs of one particular
applicant against the SpaceX and more
generally and presumably against your
other duties in the CAA um and how you
balance all of that are you sufficiently
resourced do you think now to support
the nation space industry in the UK
the evidence given by Witnesses talks to
the um very clear and active engagement
that we have now ongoing across um you
know a number of State holders and
particularly those with more mature
applications the there's a dedicated
team of 48.
um we're very well funded by DFT to
maintain that core team
but I think what we should see as
um a benefit of the of the CAA having
this role is that we are able to enroll
the rest of the organization and the
airspace team and the CAA is three times
as big as the space team and the
airspace team were really involved in
this the flight
stops team is three times the size of
the space team and the flight Ops Team
are involved particularly because of the
platform uh being a 747 and departing
from also whilst the Spaceport a
licensed Aerodrome and indeed our
airworthiness team which again is over
three times as big as the space team was
enrolled in making sure that their
knowledge and expertise in terms of the
operation of the 747
um was was used so I think the to answer
your question we have a great ability to
flex and um the the organization into
supporting uh space
um not just obviously the dedicated
space team which we would grow if needs
be but at this point in time we'd be we
believe we have the correct uh
resourcing
we lost you for a moment there but I
think we got the sense of the answer
um if I could turn to Mr McLeod in the
room if somebody else wanted to repeat
basically what
um virgin orbit did with a 747
horizontal launch would they be subject
to exactly the same uh you know test for
the license and the criteria that you
put in place around that launch or would
would it have evolved from the learning
from that launch
the tests remain the same
and if you're asking if if a virgin came
back in another form
we can depending on the contractual
Arrangements in the set of the company
the license could be transferred yes or
it might need to be reapplied for so a
number of the tests for example around
finances the skills and expertise of the
people in the organizations and
prescribed rules and law like the
security manager if they all change
obviously we have to revisit it but if
the fundamentals were the same in terms
of the safety case that will also and
the the new organizations access to that
will make it a bit easier for them
because the Virgin orbit license is
still extant the Spaceport license is
still extant but they're also very
closely aligned those two licenses and
to go back to your
the original question about the lessons
learned
I think just to expand on what Rob said
um a really key learning for us is the
is the interaction between the Spaceport
and the operator and the launch
application down in Newquay is very
closely iterated between those two
companies and this morning you heard
about Shetland who are looking to have a
multi-user Spaceport where it's a space
port with up to seven companies
potentially and then you've got orbex
which is one Spaceport and one space
company so the interactions of how that
works is really important because the
responsibilities between the Spaceport
operator and the launch operator
can be slightly different on their
contractual arrangements and just to
close off a final key learning was
actually on the on why the action
happened
we don't know the actual result formally
yet so the space accident investigation
agency which is Norm of the aib in the
UK is working with the FAA we understand
virgin have just about closed off the
report on what did happen and when that
is sent to the FAA and we have access to
it we'll be able to understand what that
means and that could also have an
influence on the ability for a future
operation using that same technology
because it depends what the cause was
and what the solution is and that will
impact on the safety case they need to
get the license to launch again in the
UK thank you um it's finally on that on
that safety case uh as I said earlier we
had other companies right in support of
your position and in your role before
before that launch one of them was
Newton launch systems who said you're
taking the correct approach to safety
but they also raise two concerns uh one
about the the proximity of the
spectators to the launch site guessing
in I'm very unlikely event of any
explosion happening on the ground and
secondly on the actual launch site
chosen was too close in their view to
the Canary Islands um an unnecessary
risk do you do you recognize either
those and you have any observations on
their comments
I think I would respond to that in terms
of the way the regulatory system works
is that the operator and the Spaceport
come to us and set out the safety case
to us we don't tell them how big it
should be where they should operate or
how they need to organize their flight
path they set out a safety analysis for
us and our team of experts look at that
and actually in the case of the the
Virgin launch which required an FAA
license as well we had excellent support
from our partners in America we're able
to compare our assessments with the FAA
assessments and in terms of the the
ground operations at Newquay Airport
Wireless space it's very similar to
other high Hazard Industries which which
we understand well in the UK and the
safety exclusion Zone that was put in
place and proposed by Spaceport Cornwall
in our view met the requirements the
mitigations that they put in place were
adequate and that's how we were able to
issue a license for their operation
and the point where I took off from in
in mid-air the loans being too close to
the Canary Islands it is is that again
you assess that with consult Consulting
with the FAA as well the fa undertook
their assessment we undertook our
assessment
we had a
a lot of support from the pardon me the
the airspace team in the CAA we organize
uh corridors of safety for aircraft
regularly this is a normal tactical
activity that takes place
um often in international space and it
was also a good
a good example exampler of how the the
CAA works with his International
counterparts in Spain Italy and Ireland
to coordinate those activities and to go
back to the comment from I think was the
chair at the start in terms of failing
safely
we set up we agreed the corridor of
airspace and that was to allow the
activity to fail safely it did fail and
it failed within parameters and there
was no risk to to aircraft because of
the the safety zones that were put in
place okay that's very helpful thank you
very much just on that point of um
shared airspace with other countries
obviously that was a bespoke solution
for the for the Virgin launch and do you
work very hard with neighboring
jurisdictions is it possible and do you
think it's desirable to establish a
framework agreement with neighboring
states that maybe useful for future
launchers without having to negotiate
each individually each time
uh yes and that's under discussion and
underway at the moment so there's two
aspects to us I talked about the
Tactical elements just now in terms of
the CAA and other Regulators
internationally managing how it happens
that the layer above that is the
political Comfort to undertake these
activities and partners airspaces and
that's where it's slightly more
complicated and that's something that
the government leads on to the
government leads on government to
government conversations with with other
states and the department for transport
is currently doing that in terms of the
airspace requirements for north of
Scotland and Shetland spaceports
yes absolutely
yes Mrs Mission carry on
my in my substantive role when I'm not
the interim joint Chief exec I'm the
safety and airspace director and I was
in the uh sort of process of swapping
sort of notes and and formal letters of
agreement with my counterparts in uh in
the uh in the countries where obviously
the Virgin orbit launch touched
um I think
foreign
what's the future opportunity to sort of
regularize that relationship is one that
we we are working through to Collins
point however I think it's really
important that the committee notes that
a lot of the basis by which those other
countries both from a safety perspective
and also a political perspective agreed
to support the activity was on the basis
of the confidence they had in the UK
today's assessment of safety and the
mitigations and that was expressly uh
made clear to me by every one of my
accountant parts that I eventually had
to swap formal notes with that it was
their confidence in the risk assessment
methodology of the UK and the fact that
they know we are very used to
um managing organizing and approving
very complex activity in our airspace
which is by definition a very complex
airspace block so I think there is a
um there is a lot to sort of Leverage in
that but also a lot to lose so if you
don't do that well if you don't do that
rigorously that confidence goes and
politically it's very easy therefore for
that collaboration to stop um if they
have that justification so I think it's
something we need to protect
um very uh very clearly indeed and so on
that if there were to be a framework
agreement to you to make permanent what
you did in the case of the Cornwall
launch is that is there a a body that
would be responsible for that or is that
in a sense a series of bilateral
discussions between the UK and other
countries and if so who is the lead is
it the CAA or is it the department for
transport
I
I the lead would be the department
transport on the policy position but in
enacting that uh
um it's it's usually the CAA Partners as
you can imagine within the north
airspace system we have
long established
and very strong relationships with um
you know a number of airspace Partners
um and those have been renewed and
refreshed uh post um exit from the EU as
well so uh that those relationships are
very strong and very productive and very
collaborative and space is just an
activity within the broader s-based
piece so I don't think we should say
it's it's different it's just a question
of maintaining that strong framework and
those relationships and information
exchanged with those uh those bordering
uh countries thank you very much uh goes
to Chris Clarkson then Tracy Crouch
thank you chair um I'd like to talk a
bit about uh Licensing in the previous
evidence session the committee heard
from a number of witnesses including the
CAA that it might be useful to have a
central body or a portal um I think Mr
Strang talks about spacer which sounds
like a Marvel movie but might not be a
bad idea um have you made any progress
in that area and you know what steps
have you taken to try and sort of
centralize that process to coordinate
all the people involved in licensing
so I'm not sure it's I'm not sure that
we said that we were going to do that
um we are learning the lessons as we
said from the first the first launch uh
we're operating at the moment with five
launch companies who are are coming
forward and we have also improved how we
coordinate with the Marine Organization
for example across airspace with the
health and safety executive there's also
local Geo geographical impacts around
what regulations may or may not be
required so it's not that there's a a
Sim there's definitely not a simple
solution to this but we are working very
closely with all these other partner
bodies to try and make sure we can
get to the companies involved earlier
with with all these regulatory bodies
that uh have to issue licenses which
support the space license would you say
from that process that you're sort of
developing almost a best practice for
how these things can be done more
efficiently we're certainly learning
good lessons as our other partner
organizations so some examples that
we've got so far as we we talked earlier
or a previous uh
speaker talked about the coma
regulations on high Hazard activities so
these are well understood regulatory
requirements for organizations in in
those environments and what we are able
to do now more clearly is when a new
applicant comes in the door we can
identify for them which organizations we
think they need to be speaking to
because ultimately the licenses for some
of these need to be issued by other
Regulators under law we can't issue uh a
Commerce certificate or license
so we can clearly signify and indicate
companies where they have to go another
good example under virgin was uh the
requirement for an explosive certificate
most Rockets
have uh use explosives to split the
stages apart under in a controlled way
but obviously there's lots of
requirements around how you handle and
store explosives safely so we've got the
expertise we're learning more and more
about how to signpost these to new
applicants when they come in the door so
they can start that Journey themselves
because they have to do it in direct
coordination with some of the other
legal bodies
So based on that do you think you'll be
able to meet these sort of the necessary
time scales to
um fulfill our vertical launch ambitions
so as we said today as I said earlier we
we haven't
failed or stopped one of these
activities taking place within the
schedule of their technical Readiness as
Sir Stephen Hillier said at the last
committee
and looking at the time scales of the
application we've got in front of us we
don't see that we're in a position that
we're going to stop any of these rocket
companies launching when they are
technically ready to launch and Our
intention and the Lessons Learned is
that as Rob said earlier we're really
moving to try and increase precedence
before launch and we are not a licensing
body we are a regulator we want to issue
the license with conditions and then
move towards much greater levels of
oversight and what that does is it gives
far greater control to the applicants to
then focus on operating safely so they
can have their license they'll have a
list of things they have to do before
they can launch and we will support and
oversee those through through to the
point of launch but they decide when
they launch not us
thank you thank you very much indeed
Tracy Crouch there's been much
consultation around the issue of the um
of a variable liability approach this
committee's report on space and
satellites recommended that the the
government should develop proposals uh
for the variable liability approach um
and that it should be implemented by
June 2023 which is obviously next month
many of our Witnesses have called for
this approach to be taken during this
committee's inquiry
um so Patrick balances report on the
pro-innovation regulation of digital
Technologies endorse this committee's
recommendation but the government in its
response said that it was finalizing its
proposal on the variable limit approach
and that it's unlikely to be implemented
now until early 2024.
um Mr McLaren I just wondered what your
views were on that delay and whether or
not you could see that there would be a
significant continuation
of disin incentive for investment which
is what some of our Witnesses think
in terms of the the proposals that's not
led by the CAA that's led by government
and I think the minister coming next
will probably speak to that because I
think there's going to be a some more
engagement with industry shortly
in terms of
Investments we certainly do not see any
reduction or change in investment at the
moment as Rob said earlier we've got
um 25 key applications in the pipeline
at the moment we've issued licenses to
19 companies in the last year and a half
from across the globe we're seeing
increasing interest from all countries
to come to the UK it's partly because of
the regulatory access and certainty that
we have it's also around the stable
legal framework in the UK which
encourages an investment to come forward
and I'm sure the minister will talk
about the proposals linking all that to
liabilities and insurance so we don't
see any reduction and to come back all
the way to the start of some of the
discussions that are in regulations
the regulations from our perspective
certainly work we've now used them in
anger in almost every application that
they could be used for but they're also
outcome focused regulation which means
they allow us to handle Innovation very
very well
because it's up to the applicant to
bring forward their new idea and show us
that it's safe and that's why we have
companies like space Forge who were in
the previous
evidence session who came up with
fantastic innovative ideas we've got
lots of new ideas around debris removal
and increasing numbers of constellations
wanting to come to the UK where we're
now an acknowledged expert I've spoken
at the United Nations in Vienna on
constellations
and our expertise of how to regulate
them for other countries and we've been
asked to go and speak again next month
so I certainly don't see any reduction
in interest in satellites or launch in
the UK okay thank you Mr Fish tomorrow
we're waiting for the minister to arrive
can I just ask completely separate
slightly Off Script question and which
is that we've heard from other Witnesses
um this morning but also previously
around the the talent pool as it were
and obviously the CAA is a technical
regulator and I just wondered are you
seeing challenges to recruitment within
the CAA what can we do in order to
improve
um Talent either being developed here or
recruited here is there do you have any
views or comments on that
yeah no thank you for the question it's
it's front and center actually uh and I
expect it to be when I resume the board
meeting shortly I expect it to be a
topic that our board continues to sort
of scrutinize and explore
um across some of not just space but
sort of new novel Technologies
um you know the Innovation sector uh I
was recently down in uh Bristol um
visiting vertical Aerospace which is an
advanced term ability platform and they
were talking to their own challenges of
recruitment
but actually again a little bit like the
story that I heard from Sky Aura
yesterday when I was on site they are as
an industry connecting into academic
organizations trying to design courses
so they get a stream of talented young
minds uh into the into these various
emerging sectors
um as a regulator we've been very active
in the stem program again supported by
DFT
um the question is we need you know do
we need to do more the answer is yes
um do we we have some skill shortages as
it stands based on some of the issues
and and Technical expertise that we need
in our system yes we've got some areas
you know that we've we've highlighted
where we need more resilience you know
software battery Specialists
um propulsion propulsion is becoming not
just in space but as you can imagine
with the sustainability challenge that
the entire Aviation ecosystem has
propulsion
um is one of the areas where we we think
we need to do uh much more much more
quickly
um so again I will be talking to some of
the activity and ideas that we've got um
in our board meeting and when I rejoin
it in a few minutes no I'm very grateful
for that for you taking the time and
again I'm I'm asking this question as a
filler for the minister who I'm sure
will be exceptionally grateful and
reward you accordingly
but um do you have um any um issues
around diversity
in the CAA and what more can be done to
encourage sort of kind of Greater
diversity within the regulator
again you know and as an executive
committee we've uh We've we've
progressed
um you know the diversity conversation
um with a lot of focus over the last uh
two or three years we we're mindful of
the challenge particularly when you're
recruiting expertise from a sector uh
where there is a lack of diversity so
you have to have a very long lens on
developing again working with academic
organizations Pathways for
um you know young people to be attracted
into the SEC into sectors now we're
seeing you know in the British
celeria
um there was a there was an emergence
there uh you know of talent and
diversity that we need to tap into as
indeed some of the innovators are
directly themselves it's no different
um I think when we engage with the space
sector we're seeing um the attraction of
being involved in these new sectors is
is drawing in interests
um from from you know a whole diverse
range of people ages genders uh
ethnicities
um we need to make sure as a regulator
we mirror that
um and so we have programs to try and
develop that
um no it's not easy uh there's no doubt
it's not easy have we moved the dial uh
the pace to the scale we would have
wished over the last two or three years
know what I would say is we have because
we're a growing organization as much as
a learning one we have the opportunity
to use future growth plans to make sure
that actually the net we throw is very
Broad and that we give every opportunity
for the most diverse sets of of
candidates to be
ultimately brought through our
recruitment processes and
equally working with industry Partners
as well so I would say at the moment is
it is it a picture that we accept no
it's not
um and there's a lot of challenge again
from uh from our board on that very
point
thank you very much Tracy can I just ask
one a final brief question to Mr McLeod
it's come up several times in this
session and in the previous panel of
witnesses that the need for a a Central
Gateway to coordinate the different
agencies uh is desirable and so Stephen
Hillier said that to us as well
who should who should establish that who
should coordinate is that within the
gift of the CAA uh or is that the space
agency or is it the department for
transport
[Music]
it's a very difficult question for me to
answer chair
um I think
we should always bear in mind we've only
done one launch so we've licensed one
Spaceport and one launcher we're still
learning the lessons from from that
I would simply hesitate to make too many
changes until we've
we've tested them again in in a couple
of more areas because as I said earlier
I think we've improved things
significantly on our engagement with the
Marine organizations health and safety
and another and other bodies
whether or not that would be an
immediate help or a hindrance or
something else we'd have to learn to do
again for the next launch I'm not sure
but certainly from the lessons we're
continuing to learn and from the next
couple of
key examples of a vertical Spaceport and
some launcher vehicles that might be the
time to to revisit that question and see
is it worth us actually doing that given
the volume of applications and the
variability between the different
applications that we get okay well um
we'll leave it there for now but very
grateful Mr McLoud for your appearance
today and for this mission for joining
us from Glasgow and for interrupting
your board meeting thank you very much
indeed I'm now going to welcome our
final panel and the pair of witnesses to
the table familiar
to this committee uh George Freeman the
minister of states in the department now
the department for science Innovation
and Technology welcome Minister and His
official Rebecca evendon who is director
of the space directorate at that
department uh thank you very much indeed
for coming we this
this hearing and its previous one were a
follow-up to the report that we issued
on space and satellites and it was
triggered in particular by the the
launch in Cornwall
that didn't succeed I think Minister you
were there at the time you were at
Newquay on the evening I seem to
remember and you you wrote to me and
wrote to the committee
to express concerns that the evidence
that we'd receive from Virgin
told one side of the the story and that
we needed a broader perspective as to
what went right and what went wrong
um so help us out what went right and
what went wrong with that launch
well firstly uh Gemma thank you for the
opportunity to come before you and um uh
I really appreciate this committee's
leadership if I can say and interest on
Space policy it's a fast growing area
and we're really grateful for the chance
to have this conversation
um
it is our view still I should just say
that uh space is difficult we've seen
since the January Virgin uh failure and
I should just say the there's a whole
series of things that go into a launch
um I don't want to pretend the whole
mission was a success but we have got
Europe's first regulated licensed
Spaceport we did get the launch away
from the UK the first firing went well
the problem was a virgin problem with
the second firing which I'm sure you've
taken evidence on
um but you know since then we've seen
jaxa in Japan have had a major problem
with one of their launches even
um SpaceX have had problems so we're in
the foothills of a very fast advancing
sector but we remain committed to our
strategic commitment that we think over
the next 10 years given the growth in
low earth observation satellite launch
the UK can realistically should and we
are realistically aiming to be the
biggest launch pad in Europe through a
number of sites two important ones
Scotland which will be the next launch
and so we remain very committed to that
in terms of the specifics of your
question there are lessons clearly to be
learned from
both from a virgin point of view
technically and that's a matter
obviously for them but from our point of
view whilst we're really proud to have
got the first Spaceport licensed and led
and and the regulations we put in place
in 2021 were important part of that
we are aware that you know there's
launch licenses orbital licenses
Spaceport licenses Marine licenses
national International airspace licenses
uh we got through all of that
um but as part of the regulatory review
under in the new Department uh I'm Keen
to make sure with officials that we
learn those lessons as well about how we
can make this a more streamlined process
without in any way undermining uh what
the public and all of us would
absolutely
rightly expect to be line one which is
Public Safety and environmental
sustainability thank you well let's um
let's come on to that here but it's
important to to recognize is the CAA in
the last panel said that the the launch
failed but it failed safely and that is
one of the uh the prime responsibilities
uh of the the cea whatever else to be
said about it uh indeed you mentioned
the the number of different bodies uh
involved and that is part of your
regulatory review you're looking at how
they could be better coordinated or
whatever
um
tell me a bit about that review when
when is it going to conclude who's
conducting it and when would its results
be available to to change the the
current practice
thank you you'll appreciate chair since
I was last before the committee we have
a whole new department and that that has
um a major part of the prime minister's
thinking behind creating decent
Department science Innovation and
technology is to make sure we're
building a more coherent landscape
across government and as part of our s t
framework we have set out regulation as
one of the key parts of it and that's
both using Innovative approaches to
regulation not to race to the bottom but
to use those brexit freedoms to set
Stampers and and perhaps we can pick up
and due course the work that we're
planning on to use those freedoms on
Space sustainability but it's also about
making sure we have a joined up
ecosystem and
um uh perhaps I can I can turn to
Rebecca in terms of when we may be able
to uh come out with something I've got a
big announcement coming in the Autumn
around regulation and my thinking have
been that we might package it up with
that but there's work going on at the
moment across the department to look at
how we can basically what the lived
experience for the applicant is when do
you expect the um this consolidation or
cooperation between the existing bodies
to take place
we what the regulatory review consists
of is a set of different activities
looking at different aspects of how we
regulate space
and part of that is looking at what we
did for launch for the first launch and
there's been a Lessons Learned process
that has been conducted looking at that
so some and that's that is still just
concluding now but some of that will be
feeding into the work that CAA and DFT
are doing looking at the Space
Industries act and looking at the
secondary legislation to see if there's
anything in the future that we might
want to come back and revisit
um the space agency is about to publish
a consultation
um on the orbital liability
um which I know has been an issue that
the committee has raised before and
which we've listened to and which of
course was picked up in the valance
regulatory review as well so there will
be a consultation coming out on that
shortly
um essentially saying that we accept
that we do need to do this we do need to
have orbital liability limits and
licenses and working with industry as to
how we best do that and then there's a
sort of third aspect of it as well which
is sustainability and how we use our
regulatory framework to best drive those
Ambitions that we've got for a
sustainable space environment so this is
the work that we're doing both through
the UN but also domestically with
industry to develop a voluntary standard
which we're calling the sustainability
Mark which will help us to set standards
to enable us to license both launch
activities and orbital activities in a
way that drives those sustainable
behaviors so all of those things are
under this bracket that we are I'm
calling the regulatory review and we
would hope to make some progress by the
Autumn across the base all three bases
on this point about bringing together
and better coordinating the the large
number of bodies involved when do you
expect that to be to be different
in terms of the experience of the
companies in the sector
as I could say we I mean firstly I Don't
Want To Tread on my excellent colleague
Jesse Norman's toes as Minister for CAA
at DFT he and I DFT and DC worked
incredibly closely together in the lead
up to the Virgin launch and we're
working very closely in terms of
learning the lessons from Virgin I think
that's the sort of first starting point
um obviously they lead on the CAA
regulatory piece we're leading more on
trying to make sure that the lived
experience across the whole ecosystem
for applicants is more streamlined and
more coherent and to be honest we all
learned a lot through preparing new key
and living through that launch and we
very much hope that the Scottish
launches will be rather easier and more
streamlined as a result of it but I'm
happily happy to take the action Mr the
chair to come back to you I mean in my
mind there's an Autumn moment where
we're going to be setting out our
sustainability specific regulatory
proposals for the sustainable kind Mark
for Accelerated licensing cheaper
insurance but cheaper Finance for
compliant companies and at that point I
would certainly want us to have
completed that so perhaps I can come
back to you then we've heard throughout
our main inquiry in the follow-up
inquiry is just what what pace there is
in the sector and that other companies
are advancing quickly and Minister and
indeed resident you you both know this
very well so we do need to get on with
it
um is it not possible to to make some
early progress on this before the the
Autumn you don't need to wait to to hold
things back for a big announcement do
you if you've made some progress already
no I'm with respect I think we are
moving at a pace that
um
I mean space is moving quickly and
having come back from the G7 I tell you
we're winning plaudits for the pace and
leaders ship we're providing on
sustainability on European launch on
insisting on International
Global collaboration so if we can come
back more quickly
we will but there are some quite
important both across government but
also International pieces that have to
be sorted around making sure that
um you know in terms of the
sustainability piece that links to un uh
it links to pulling other countries
along with us I've been building a
Consortium of space Nations around the
world who agree with us so that we're
not isolated on this so there's a lot of
work going on behind the scenes but I
absolutely take your challenge and if we
can come back to you with the proposals
on this regulatory Lessons Learned we'll
do so before the summer thanks very much
um just um finally from specifically on
the Cornwall launch obviously that was a
great disappointment to uh to everyone
what steps is the government taking to
make sure that the the lessons that were
learned and in particular the progress
made at Spaceport Cornwall and we were
very impressed by the evidence that we
heard from Spaceport Cornwall it great
shame if that did not succeed in the
future are you able to do anything
minister to to make sure that that
Spaceport has a future with or without
virgin yes we are and um
I completely agreed what you said in our
past to Rebecca to just brief you on the
specifics of that piece of work but we
see Spaceport Cornwall as I mean it it's
a flagship space but it's the first
licensed space port in Europe uh it is
uh or now as a result of the Virgin
launch receiving a number of and in a
number of important conversations with
other launch parties uh both here around
the world who want to
consider it as a base for launch indeed
I've just come back from Japan where
jaxa said look we're very keen to pursue
Jackson launches from the UK so there's
a raft of ongoing launch conversations
that I'm delighted new Keys baseball to
having they are a commercial
organization and pay tribute to their
energy and pace and as well as I mean
this interim period while the next
launches are sorted uh they have rightly
and impressively set up their Enterprise
and Innovation Hub and at the heart of
that's Cornish space cluster with goon
hilly down the road Earth observation
coding we see them not just as a launch
Center but a hub for the commercial
small companies that are emerging in
this space but I'll pass to Rebecca to
talk you through the specifics of what
we're doing thank you just briefly if
you would miss we've got other things we
want to go on but uh but what are you
doing to make sure the Cornwall
continues as a Spaceport
well two main things uh the UK space
agency continues to work with space
space book Cornwall to help identify any
future launch providers that might wish
to launch from there
um for example there's a new mou that
the Spaceport signed with Sierra space
in order to you know perhaps bring
Sierra space
um to use cornwall's facilities so
that's a positive development
um and then the other thing ministers
already mentioned is supporting Cornwall
through the broader clusters funding so
that they can develop the cluster as a
whole and be an attractive place for
space businesses to come into so those
are the two main structures all right
thank you very much let's go to
um our colleagues starting with Aaron
Bell and then Chris Lawson thank you
thank you Minister and Miss Everton as
well
um if I can just follow up a couple of
follow-ups from the chairs questions you
talked about what the progress at
Spaceport Cornwall not being wasted is
the department taking any interest in
the uh what's happened to Virgin orbit
itself which is currently going through
bankruptcy protection in Delaware I
understand and is hoping to sell this
assets perhaps to strato launch has the
department taken any interest at the
government taking any interest in what's
happening there and trying to secure
essentially the the you know the company
not being broken up so that we can they
could get back whoever purchased it to
Cornwall as soon as possible
yes we have taken a close interest
um but let me just stress from the point
of view of um recognizing virgin as a
private company it's a commercial
operation it's up to them to decide how
and where they fit in this fast
moving Global race
um we are Keen to make sure that we
develop and we deliver Our obligation
which was our commitment which is to
make the UK a leading Leo launch
destination for all and every and any
providers who want to come here so we
are
Keen to make sure that every opportunity
for maintaining value in the UK is
pursued
um but we're not sitting here you know
thinking of making a major acquisition
and acquiring and developing a UK
Sovereign launch capability understood
um uh given we heard from the CAA the
licens is still extant for Virgin to
launch there has anyone saw any
undertakings any potential purchases of
Virgin or which assets of the A1 sort
any potential undertakings from the
government or from the CAA about the the
fact that that license would be
transferable to anyone who purchased the
company
well as I said matters for the CAA would
have to be addressed really to DFT and
my colleague Jesse Norman as the
minister I'd just say we you know in as
Minister for the space industry Here We
Stand ready to support a specific
proposal that looks sustainable
financially sustainable and commercially
sustainable but we're not looking or in
the business of making a major UK
investment in acquiring
um a platform that hasn't worked but
we're keen to make sure we support
people who want to build and grow here
in the UK thank you Minister and just on
the overall regulation point and the
desire that we've heard for to have a
central entity or portal Dan Hart the
CEO of Virgin orbit um listed and I will
list them quickly because it's it's of
interest and I think should be on a
record the different organizations they
did have to deal with civilization
Authority UK space agency coat for
transport health and safety executive
Maritime and Coast Guard agency memory
management organization UK hydrographic
office Coast Guard the maritime rescue
coordination Center the ministry of
Defense National Air Traffic Services
Cornwall police at the airport fire
department and MI5 now they've all got a
valid interest here and I'm sure than
your excellent new department has an
interest as well so they maybe add it to
the list but that he he said that it's
it's not just the fact that you had to
deal with these they were being asked
for the same information rehashed again
and again
um you've said you want to put that
right
um would that be a separate organization
or would that be something that sits
with the CIA in Your Vision firstly um
yes and that's why am I opening months I
made the point that
um you know it is no mean feat to
achieve first launch from Europe
um and there are a lot of lessons to be
learned and one of them that I wanted to
highlight was that regulatory alignment
each of the organizations you've
mentioned I think do have a role and
have an important statute Duty and we
need to make sure that the public can
see we are not cutting any corners and
that we're doing space
launch in a sustainable and safe way but
um inevitably the first time you do
something
you're breaking new ground and there's a
lot of lessons about how we can do it
more quickly next time and how we can
not repeat and Not Duplicate without in
any way undermining different statutory
obligations so
um as per the earlier question
um Minister normally King to make sure
that across the board
we've got a more streamlined system it's
easier and people aren't asked the same
questions again and it shouldn't be
beyond the winter government when we've
asked a set of questions this goes
across into other sectors like Health as
well when you've asked somebody a set of
questions
you should be able to capture them
digitally and use them in the next
application rather than require them to
keep giving you the same information so
at a very basic level uh we really ought
to be able to make it more streamlined
you think that would be a government a
central government function rather than
the ca because you probably caught the
last answer as you as you came in from
this year I think they're a little
reluctant to take on that Clearinghouse
role given that they want to specialize
in what they do best we don't in any way
want to undermine the statutory duties
of each regulator but we do want to make
sure that for the point of view of
applicants the system and the process is
more streamlined and clear and that
should be possible in a 21st century and
that could be divided by DFT or decent
as a government function yeah we view it
as an important part of delivering the s
t framework the Balance review smarter
more digital and agile regulation in the
global race
um so it's across government
responsibility thank you
okay thank you very much indeed Chris
locks and then Rebecca lombelly thank
you chair so Patrick balance has
endorsed this committee's recommendation
about moving towards a variable
liability
um system by June of this year the
government's indicated now that it's
looking at doing this perhaps in early
2024.
um obviously I know from my own
experience working with you Minister
you're a doer and you're trying to make
this a lived experience um more more
accessible for people uh so will you be
taking these steps to expedite that
process and you know what steps will you
be taking in order to ensure the
competitiveness of the sector
yes
um as
as Rebecca just said we had taken uh the
advice of that we'd heard by this
committee and others and we've made the
move and the commitment to address it
um perhaps I can invite Rebecca to
explain the timetable and any options
for accelerating it
well the consultation is being led by
the UK space agency
um and we we want to leave enough time
during that consultation for industry to
respond so that we actually get the
right answer here so I think you could
expedite it but but actually you
probably need a bit of time for the
industry for the insurance Community to
think about what they want to say and I
think you know if the consultation is
being published next month which I
believe is the aim
um and we'll close I think in at the end
of September then a couple of months
after that for the government to publish
its response in early 2024 I think is is
a is a fairly reasonable timeline for
what will be quite a significant policy
change for the government and I think
once you've signaled that this is what
you intend to do that is the important
thing and businesses will take that
signal positively at least that's what
we're hearing from industry and be able
to make their investment decisions based
on the signals that they're hearing from
government about the direction of travel
we do plan a major moment as I mentioned
in October where we'll be setting out uh
the detail of our new sustainability
regulatory framework we've got a working
group with Lloyds of London the city of
London space agency and decent officials
we do intend that to be quite a moment
where the UK sets out a new regulatory
framework that rewards those that are
compliant with quicker access to
financing cheaper insurance and if we
can do it speedier regulatory approval
so this all goes to a piece and I think
without compromising
the importance of Industry having a
clear voice if we can get it out before
the end of Q4 it might
you know it's all to the good in terms
of showing leadership in a new
regulatory framework yeah so I mean
obviously the law room is slightly
cynical so when I say by phrase like
early 2024 uh you know I have to ask
what is early 2024 but if you're saying
now possibly by Q4 is this just a case
of making sure the due diligence is done
before anything sort of goes out yes
there's no reason to hold it back uh and
every reason I think as long as we've
had proper consultation from industry
and it fits with that package that we've
announced in October we don't want to
give contradictory signals
um if I could I would love to get it
away by the end of 24 and if it means at
the end of 23 and if it means early 24
I'm thinking the first week of 24 rather
than
um you know
q1 takes us through to Easter okay thank
you very much Mr thank you very much
Rebecca and then Tracy thank you and Mr
the publication of a national position
navigation and timing strategy that's a
capability that's critical to UK
infrastructure can you confirm whether a
strategy will be published and what the
timelines for this will be
um great question yes I can confirm that
we
um you'll appreciate Miss Long Bailey
the the scale in the last and the pace
in the last year
of international
geopolitical interest in pnt we've seen
since the appalling invasion of Ukraine
by the Russians just in the last 12
months a huge
geopolitical race for access to an
integrated approaches by allies to
some of that pnt technology and data and
and so there's a huge amount going on
indeed it was an important topic at the
G7
where we were
Frameworks for integrated commercial
data use in space that also allow for
proper secure use and security uses by
trusted allies and partners so it's very
live and it's something that we are
discussing in the economic security
cabinet committee that the prime
minister's set up perhaps I could turn
to Rebecca for again timings and
likelihood of when we may be when we
expect to be able to put something out
um yes I can comment although the pnt
team doesn't sit within my remit so it
sits within a parallel team with
indecent
uh that's because
um the government took the decision to
establish a cross-government approach to
pnt that was the significant step I
believe that was taken last year so
rather than this being the remit of a
single Department which meant that
progress was quite difficult
um other departments came together to to
form a single unit to look at both
terrestrial and space
um uh interests in pnt and the use cases
and I know that team has made good
progress over the past few months and
have concluded their demonstrator
project and recommendations are going to
ministers at the moment to conclude that
and to set out next steps so I think
subject to all of that I would hope that
you would hear from the pnt team
um you know within not a very long
amount of time what those what those
next steps are likely to be okay so are
we looking within the next few months
I would expect so but as I said this
isn't within my remit at the moment but
certainly I would expect that to be the
case yes my note says the project team
is in the final stages of assembly
evidence for ministers well final stages
sounds to me like weeks
I'll happily come back to you this long
Bailey on that if um if I made it's a
helpful question lovely thank you and
one very brief question
um insofar as the the strategies being
developed at the moment are you aware
that it's going to involve the use of
one web satellites
uh well that's another
um very interesting question
um let me take it from the top firstly
um
the
one webs future direction is obviously a
matter for one web it's a business
subject to commercial Freedom we are
delighted and I think I've said to this
committee before I inherited our golden
share and if I hadn't inherited it I'd
be sitting here saying if only we had a
golden share in a the world's biggest
Leo constellation an independent global
commercial business and I'm really
delighted that they've achieved that
status with their 670 second I think it
is satellite and they're obviously in
discussion at the moment with utilsat
which is commercial and I wouldn't want
to
and compromise it by commenting on it
except to say that we do view our
shareholding in one web as a major lever
for our commercial space strategy and we
are in discussion with as you'd expect
the various Partners in Esa and in the
EU indeed I've just been discussing it
with European Partners at the G7 the we
believe there's a very significant
win-win here if one web decide through
the util South acquisition that they
want to be and can be part of the
European Iris
system then there ought to be enough
there to go around for all parties to
benefit we would certainly want to make
sure that through our golden share we
have a significant piece of
manufacturing here in the UK and
potentially launch uh here in the UK and
there are some big issues uh sitting
within the EU at the moment around how
we make sure that a global and
Commercial open constellation can also
provide the right
PMT security there are Technical
Solutions to that I shouldn't go any
further but we think it's perfectly
possible for the UK to secure our pnt
strategic military and defense PMT
requirements in with oneweb as part of a
European constellation the two are not
in conflict
oh thank you record on the p t strategy
we took evidence during our main inquiry
that the p t strategy had already been
developed it had been consulted on
within the industry and yet it still
hasn't come to you Minister I think it
must have been 2021 when we uh when we
heard that it was being discussed
we've discussed the pace that's required
in this is is there is there sufficient
recognition of the need for Pace within
the department
let me just be clear and in 2021 I saw I
mean it's not that I'm waiting to see
the first
uh first documents on this
um there's been substantial conversation
across government and departments
there's a number who have an interest in
this obviously
um what we're waiting for is the final
set of proposals
for us to
agree and sign off if you saw the first
set of proposals in 2021
it's taking an awful long time to to get
to the uh to the final ones is it not
what what's the what's the problem well
as I commented earlier um so I returned
to government at the just for Christmas
in 2021
um you'll be aware 2022 was both a
military and political
politically and militarily tumultuous
year we had war in Europe we had uh huge
focusing government on dealing with and
responding to all of that we've had some
political turmoil and we've now had the
creation of a new Department uh and I'm
saying the creation of the new
department has delayed things further no
I'm saying that the Prime Minister has
made strategic grip of global s t for
the UK in the context of Global Security
uh far more of a priority than it was
back in 21 as a result of Ukraine these
conversations are very live and UT is
very important to to the space sector
the space sector is very important to
our Science and Technology Ambitions and
indeed to the country so it would follow
I would hope that the creation of a new
department and the appointment of the
Prime Minister with these Ambitions you
know we're back in the Autumn might
accelerate this and yet here we are in
May and we still don't have the p t
strategy that was referred to in draft
in 2021 yes I don't for the reasons I've
set out I I don't accept that that is as
it may look to you a period of
inactivity at all quite the opposite
it's been a period of
extraordinarily intense International
uh collaboration around pnt in the face
of an actual security threat both
military in Europe and economic threats
to supply chains and so there are a raft
of
um very strategic conversations going on
about uh our 5i alliance orcas and how
much we need to respond to make sure
that key critical
um
Supply chains and Facilities like
um this are within uh secure
Partnerships with secure allies so
please don't take the lack of the
announcement of a strategy with this
committee as in action at all quite the
opposite well that's very helpful to
hear but um uh you've heard from was
evident that uh
something's coming to ministers and you
interpret that from your experiences
being weeks you'd agree with the
committee I hope that that it couldn't
in contrast be any more than weeks given
the importance of it and the time that's
been taken already well I can only speak
for myself but yes um but equally the
complexity of this it I mean it does
cross Ministry of Defense prime
minister's office
um treasury decent there's a huge number
of conversations that have just come out
of the G7 around security so I'm not
this doesn't sit only with me but uh I
think I've been pretty clear this is
geopolitically and economically
important uh and Urgent for clarity in
This Global race for space okay final
questions from Tracy Crouch well
speaking of cross-government discussions
uh the previous prime minister uh
disbanded the National Space Council it
was re-established by this prime
minister but as an interministerial
group has it met yet
uh good question so as the capital s c
space Council no it hasn't met yet
um and that's for a number of reasons
partly that space the creation of the
nstc which was also
disbanded by the last prime minister and
reinstated
by the current prime minister so the
National Science and Technology Council
which is the Strategic it's the s t
equivalent of the National Security
Council where we take the big decisions
about strategic Technologies and sectors
space
um has been uh included in the list of
areas where the nstc needs to not least
for the reasons we've just discussed uh
lead and the creation of the new
Department with me as minister of state
with the responsibility for space and
the department convening s t across
government has meant that
right now we are focusing on delivering
the Space strategy that we set out in
October 21 and the various topics we've
we've considered it is my view that
actually we
ought to convene rather as we do in
other key sectors like life sciences the
life science Council brings together
industry leaders big medium and small
political leaders and I think the space
Council should be constituted as a
leadership forum for the nascent and
emerging space sector which isn't quite
how it was originally constituted and I
I actually personally think it would be
a good thing for us to do but I think
first of all we need to deliver some of
the key things that we've been talking
about this morning so I I would like to
see the space Council up and running and
having its first meeting
um before the end of this year certainly
particularly perhaps given the
announcements we're making in September
October that would be a good time I'm
slightly surprised and shocked actually
with that response um because I think
that this is obviously a thriving
industry which government is making a
huge amount of it's value to the economy
is is enormous the supply chain
ecosystem is is fantastic
um it's driving talent and interest from
around the world
um
repeatedly throughout the session about
the cross-government nature of space
policy
um
to deliver a strategy you need that
support from all your colleagues across
departments so for the interministral
group to by the sounds of it not even
have been populated with ministers let
alone
have had a meeting is I think a bit
disappointing
um
I just thought that to be clear that's
not the case sorry I didn't mean to give
that impression the space Council as it
was originally proposed hasn't met I
have a regular routine meetings with the
minister for defense procurement who
leads at space the chancellor and I just
last week convene the latest in a series
of round tables with industry leaders in
number 11. we have a routine Hartley
series of meetings with space UK I work
very closely with Minister Norman on the
CAA so there is I didn't want you to
feel that the fact that the space
Council hasn't met
is not it's not the fact that there
isn't extremely close cooperation across
government
so in that case was the previous prime
minister right to scrap it
because it sounds like it no as I said
in my answer you need in my view you
need ministers to do heavy lifting with
their officials across government
um space councils life science councils
councils provide a different role which
my view is that they they're not really
delivery boards their annual
moments where the whole of the sector
comes together and looks at the kpis and
looks at the delivery and I think as we
bed in the delivery of this Space
strategy we need to make sure that we've
got a really coherent system across
government with the right people around
the table who represent not just the big
corporates but the emerging companies
the smes the investors and so I would
like that space Council to reflect the
the new space economy that's taking
shape here in the UK
um time is short and as much as I'd like
to keep probing you on this I think um
be useful perhaps if you could write to
the committee with perhaps
the vision for the council when you
expect it to be yeah expecting it to be
doing because at the moment it doesn't
feel like there's much urgency within
that I have one final question just um
uh from Witnesses this morning
um which is Around Talent
um and there was a desire to sort of
kind of grow the talent pool again
referring back to the fact that it's
really it's a thriving industry
um
what conversations are you having with
home office colleagues in order to
ensure that visas
um are being appropriately made
available to high skilled workers that
want to come work in the UK space sector
yes thank you this is a really important
issue and it's it's important in our
Space strategy it was one of the key
elements it's a really important part of
the s t strategy where skills talent and
resourcing is one of the Essential
Elements and that's why I've asked space
UK to provide for us a skills map over
the next 10 years of exactly what the
jobs are going to be creating what the
skills gaps are sexually and regionally
which we're still waiting for I believe
um let me pass to Rebecca for the detail
on how we
um uh look to implement that over the
next few years in terms of visas uh the
um
you'll have noticed the government set
out a number of Fast Track visas
recently visas for graduates for
scientists for entrepreneurs
and one of the reasons that I've asked
the space space UK to provide us with
that map is that as with other sectors
um we need to make sure we've got the
actual numbers and I think they're going
to be quite substantial numbers over the
next 10 years so that we can lock in
with Minister Rob Halford Department of
Education and make sure that Fe and he
colleges are actually providing well
what's coming before you do Passover so
forgive me and I know that we've got to
go to privacy question but you started
your evidence by saying how fast-paced
this sector is how it's moving
constantly we're hearing from Witnesses
about the sort of kind of global race on
this asking people to go and weigh and
draw your skills map sounds like
something that is not very urgent in
terms of its deliverables people are
crying out for talent into the sector
now so could I encourage you to sort of
kind of go away and reflect on that and
the on how we're getting people now into
yes thank you to be clear I asked in
February for not a complicated map just
a list very basic practical list of what
the UK space sector led by space UK the
commercial body
see as this actual skills required so
that we can get into the specifics of
what's needed where
thank you very much sir Tracy just one
final question for me you mentioned the
space Council should be looking at kpis
but there aren't any kpis perhaps this
is the reason the space Council hasn't
met because the the Space strategy
doesn't include them as we pointed out
in our report in the government's
response to our report it said that it
acknowledged the importance of
monitoring and evaluating progress and
said a monitoring and evaluation
framework is being developed by dsit it
hasn't appeared when is it going to I've
just signed it off and I turned to
Rebecca to um confirm when it's coming
it's a very important part of setting
out the 10-year delivery plan and how
we're doing on it each year so we're
working towards a education which will
set out how we've made progress against
the Space strategy and set out where
we're going to go next over the the next
sort of couple of years kpis and so that
will set out yes progress and the
monitoring and evaluation so when is it
going to be published
um
on the kpis this is part of a broader
departmental focus of mind that I want
to see not just that we've ticked off
the things we said we would do in the
strategy but that we set co-investment
targets we show what we're using how
we're turning our five zillion when is
it when's it going to be published if
you've signed it off
well we'll wait for the um we have to go
to the right round so get Collective
Agreement on it that will happen very
shortly it's been signed off by
ministers in dsit Collective Agreement
and then we're hoping to get this
published before the summer recess
that's our goal
uh thank you very much Vanessa thank you
Ms evendon uh for your evidence that
concludes this hearing of the committee
order